Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show I'm your
host Paul aka Michael A Hole Jordan and in
this video we're breaking down the sixth episode
of Marvel's What If.
The episode has several easter eggs that call
back to the beginning of the MCU and throughout
this we'll be talking about the hidden details,
things you missed and also giving our thoughts
for where things are going with the series.
Because of this there's gonna be a sh** load
of spoilers so if you haven't had a chance
to check it out then I highly recommend that
you check out now. If you enjoy the video
then please smash the thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe for a partnership
between us that's gonna be more iconic than
Kilmonger and Tony Stank.
With that out the way, thank you for clicking
this, now lets get into the video.
Ok so the episode is heavily tied into not
only the beginning of the MCU but also Black
Panther and Age Of Ultron. Michael B Jordan
returns as Kilmonger who is regarded by many
as being the best baddie in the entire Saga.
In the same Year that Thanos rocked the universe
in Infinity War, Michael B was picking up
best villain trophies at the MTV Movie awards
and it's clear his character left a big impression.
Not only does this see the return of several
dead characters such as Tony Stark and Killmonger
but we also get Ulysses Claw which Andy Serkis
teased at on his Instragram the other day.
Now we pick up in the Kunar province of Afghanistan
to see Tony stark travelling out to do the
Jericho missile demonstration for the US government.
Not to get to Woki but I've always viewed
Iron Man as a metaphor for War On Terror in
the Middle East and Asia.
Don't click out yeah, no but the first Iron
Man film is very much about a man who sold
weapons in Afghanistan realising how bad that
was.
Though there's a lot of people who think the
MCU only started doing social commentary recently
that movie very much set the stage for how
superheroes would operate if they existed
in real life and the issues that they would
wrestle with. After seeing first hand the
damage that had been done he decided to take
not only his company but also his personal
drives and ambitions in a completely different
direction. Up until this point his genius
had been used for personal gain at the expense
of others whereas he realised that he should
try and help the world rather than hinder
it. Western might could be used in a positive
or negative way and it's interesting to see
how things are changed up for this episode
with his path completely changing.
Now this shot is actually the first thing
that we ever got in the MCU and it's amazing
how the creative team have perfectly managed
to recapture the scenes.
This entire sequence is pulled directly from
the opening of Iron Man and it works so well.
I've placed the opening side by side here
so you can see how they line up but we watch
the Funvee convoy as it moves across the desert
before moving inside of it to watch Tony taking
a photo.
Tony mocked the idea of peace because he'd
be out of the job with peace but throughout
the saga he changed his mind and often used
peace as a driving force for his actions.
Upon leaving the cave in the first Iron Man
film the first thing he did to the helicopter
was hold up two fingers to symbolise this.
In the senate hearing during Iron Man 2 he
also help up a peace sign and used the phrase
peace in our time when talking about why he
and Bruce needed to create Ultron.
This all came full circle in Avengers Endgame
when Tony fully buried the hatchet with Captain
America. Upon returning to Avengers HQ and
giving him the shield he said that all he
wanted was peace and I love how this entire
thing comes full circle from this.
The first time we were introduced to Tony
was his hand holding up a glass of whiskey
and the subtext of this scene painted him
out as an egotistical and self centred character
who was only really out for himself.
The MCU is great at bringing things full circle
and though it might not be intentional I've
always loved the way that we were introduced
to Tony with him doing something self centered
with his hand which juxtaposes his death in
which he's doing something with his hand that's
for the betterment of everyone.
Yes it's a reach but back to the episode.
Now after the convoy is attacked we see as
the ride is fired upon and Tony flees the
vehicle to hide behind a rock. I believe he
calls out to Obidiah who we learned in Iron
Man was actually behind the attack.
It's at this point he comes face to face with
his legacy when a missile lands and we see
the Stark Industries Logo emblazened on the
side of it. This iconography would be later
brought up in Age of Ultron and Wandavision
when Wanda talked about her childhood trauma
in which one of Stark's missiles was used
to kill her parents and destroy her home.
Again looking at all these moments side by
side they line up so well and it really shows
the attention to detail that Marvel have put
into this show. Now whereas in the original
film, the shrapnel from it embedded itself
into Tony's armour and then cut through to
his heart. Tony is saved by Killmonger who
arrives and throws the missile away.
Here are two very important distinctions as
this was the first time that a suit of armour
saved Tony's life whereas in What If he is
of course saved by someone that he goes onto
strike somewhat of a partnership with. Because
of these moments diverting, the MCU version
would go onto create a minature Arc reactor
and it does kinda annoy me that he didn't
call it the Stark Reactor, which is what I
would have.
Interestingly Killmongers father's ring which
he wore around his neck is missing but we'll
talk about that later on in the video. Now
Kilmonger actually mentions in Black Panther
that he was operating in the Middle East so
it makes sense that he'd appear here.
When fighting T'Challa he said:
"I killed inAmerica,Afghanistan...Iraq.
I took life from my own brothers and sisters
right here on thiscontinent! And all this
death... just so I could kill you."
Killmonger was a highly decorated Navy Seal
and it's great seeing him back in the same
soldiers uniform that he showed up wearing
in Wakanda. It's one of the coolest character
designs in the MCU for me and it's so good
to see it back.
Now we learn that Kilmonger had actually infiltrated
the Ten Rings which were of course the organisation
that kidnapped Tony Stark. The Ten Rings of
course popped up recently in Shang-Chi and
the Ten Rings were the criminal Empire that
Wenwue had built up over millenia.
They're heading inbound but Killmonger saves
the day and thus Tony retains some of his
more charming personality traits.
Cut to a shot of the MCU version in which
he hammered away in the cave and created the
Mark 1 suit. This black vest that we see is
a very important and it has appeared at several
points throughout the saga including Iron
Man 2, Iron Man 3 and Avengers Endgame. It
tends to be used when Tony is at his weakest
point and he needs to build his way out and
it's very important iconography.
The sound of his hammering also appeared at
the end of Avengers Endgame as the credits
rolled and with the multiverse opening up
there is potential for his return.
Now in my first video I said this might be
Kilmonger due to the cracks but you know,
your boy takes Ls too so shoutouts everyone
who said I was wrong. You got me.
Next we get the infamous Avengers Assemble
shot and close out on Tony's final act. These
are all perfectly recaptured by the What If
animators and it makes you realise how much
the MCU would change without tony.
Now his film of course ended with a press
conference with him announcing to the world
that he was Iron Man. Here we see a similar
scene but instead he's annoucing to the world
that Killmonger is here.
With him is Obidiah Stane who now is no longer
a villain because Tony is continuing down
this selfish path, Pepper and Happy. I love
how they sneer at Killmonger as they have
him sussed out already.
We learn that he's now the chief of security
and as we know from Iron Man 3, Happy would
end up becoming Forehead of Security which
he remarks was meant to be his promotion.
Rather than learning any introspective lessons
from the cave, this Tony states that they
need to build bigger and badder.
Amongst the journalists you might also recognise
Christine Everheart who did a big...big spread
on Tony in the first Iron Man movie. She correctly
figured out that Tony was Iron Man and at
the press conference when he announced it
she was the only one who didn't stand up because
she already knew.
Again she asks the tough question and it was
actually Christine that spurred Tony onto
act when she presented him with Photographs
of his weapons.
Killmonger reveals he knew of the assasination
op and Obidiah panics and tries to shut it
down because as Killmonger reveals, he was
involved in it. Man brought the receipts and
amongst them we see the Ten Rings. In the
centre are two swords and you might have noticed
in the post credits scene of Shang-Chi that
this was changed once [SPOILER}
Happy gets to show off his boxing prowess
and we journey to Tony's Miama beach house.
Killmonger is appointed as the new COO much
to Pepper's disapproval and she of course
went onto get this poistion in Iron Man 3.
Rhodey arrives and we see him played by Don
Cheadle rather than Terrence Howard who of
course took the role in the original film.
He brings up that Killmonger was from Oakland
which is where we were introduced to the character
at the start of Black Panther.
They travel into tony's garage and we see
the set of sports cars that he has including
the hot rod on the end which would go onto
inspire the colours of the Iron Man Armour.
We discover that he's been working on repulsor
tech but rather than being for his suit its
for the jericho missile which has been minaturised
into a portal firearm. See women, size does
matter, sometimes the smaller the better.
Killmonger brings up his father's catchphrase
that Peace Means Having A bigger stick than
the other guy which Tony mentioned during
the first Iron Man film.
Now as my wife says sometimes it's better
to have a smaller stick Paul, and we see Dum-E
come in and grab the gun off him. See even
Dum-E knows.
Dum-E was actually Tony's first invention
and it was a cool bit of comedic relief throughout
the iron man trilogy.
Killmonger says that his father was killed
by Gang violence and later see that he kept
his ring but rather than having it on show
he hid it away so that questions wouldn't
be asked about it.
In black panther he has it on show at all
times but this changing highlights that his
mindstate has changed and he's somewhat hidden
his motives away in order to infiltrate Wakanda
through a different means.
He inspires Tony to create a drone army and
as Ivan Vanko said Drone better. Clearly the
idea of drones was matched by Vanko who shared
similar technological skills and I like that
this is somewhat a callback to Iron Man 2
to show us where weapons technology would've
gone had Tony not became Iron Man.
We see Killmongers design for this which looks
like it was ripped right out of Gundam and
Tony creates a more efficient design. Now
you might catch that the character is starting
to drink more and more and this idea of Tony
being an alcoholoic is ripped right out of
the pages of Demon in a bottle. In that Tony
became dependent on Alcohol and though the
MCU dealt somewhat with his mental health
issues in Iron Man 3 they never out and out
painted him out to be an alcoholic.
What I appreciate about What If is that even
though it's a cartoon they still go after
dark themes and there's a lot of subtext to
Tony constantly ordering up drinks.
We see him taking the design apart and the
scene massively mirrors him creating the Iron
Man suit.
They even have an operations test which feels
like it's ripped right out of Tony testing
the flight pattern of the mark too. Jarvis
will be put in control of the drones and this
is somewhat this timelines version of him
getting to be in a synthetic body.
Tony theorises building a minature arc reactor
but he shuts the idea down and Killmonger
ends up using his father's ring which is made
of Vibranium. Tony says his father used the
last of it during the war and this was of
course to make Cap's shield in the first avenger.
It wasn't really the last of it but Wakanda
hid away their source and this is why Klaw
ended up attacking the country so that he
could get more.
They scan the ring and this circular mesh
that breaks down it's elemental structure.
Something similar appeared in Iron Man 2 when
Tony was creating a new element and it's sort
of like poetry they rhyme.
Realising they need more they reach out to
Klaw who is operating out of the salvage yard
on the african coast that we first saw pop
up in Age Of Ultron.
It's at this point that the US military start
dealing with black market sellers and this
is the type of thing that Tony wanted to avoid
in the first Iron Man film. In Age Of Ultron
we learned from Klaue that he knew Tony due
to the machines speech patterns. Turns out
Klaue has a wealth of Vibranium including
not only a dora milaje spear but also several
containers of the stuff.
At this moment the lights go down and it's
when bLack Panther rolls into town taking
everyone down one by one including Klaues
right hand man who you might recognise from
Age Of Ultron.
This scene including the flash lights and
the firing on T'Challa feels like it's ripped
right out of the opening of Black Panther
and it's such a cool action scene in the middle
of the movie. It's kinda heartbreaking and
the actor was of course severly ill at this
point but still pushing through it even though
every day would've been extremely painful.
What If has managed to be the perfect way
to say goodbye to his character and he's left
behind several brilliant performances in the
series.
Klaue calls him cuz and the pair were of course
cousins and then he uneleashes the paralysing
sonic taser which Obidiah had a minature version
of in the first film.
Killmonger kills T'Challa and takes his armour
before revealing his true plans and making
a union with Klaue much like how he did in
the MCU. Turns out that he's been using Tony's
wealth and privelge to open doors that he
never could have and he's been working his
own agenda in order to overthrow Wakanda.
T'Challa and Rhodey's body are taken away
and we see the similarities between the fallen
soldier coffins which are carried by the soldiers
of their country.
We see King T'Chaka, Ramonda and also a younger
Shuri.
In the timeline we were in 2008 rather than
the age she was in Black Panther hence why
she's still a kid. I think that happens in
2016 but Homecoming kinda messed everything
up so who even knows at this point. Screw
you sony.
We also see General Ross meeting Rhodey's
and you will of course know him from several
films in the MCU.
T'Chaka goes to the UN and this is similar
to the post credits scene of Black Panther.
It also riffs slighlty on Civil War as it
was in that that Wakandans had been killed
and he was about to address his people being
killed at the hands of The Avenngers.
We learn that Tony discovered what Killmonger
was up to and he used the same holographic
technology that appeared in Iron Man 3 to
survey the site of the extremis explosion.
Killmonger arrives to take him out in his
own home and this was somewhat mirrored in
Obidiah who did the same thing in the first
Iron Man movie.
This time Tony is prepared though and we watch
as he activates his own quoute unquoute iron
man to kill Killmonger and much in the same
way that Tony was able to scan Cap's fight
patter and counteract it, the drone can do
the same.
Killmonger says he's gonna have to freestyle
it and his shirt is ripped off revealing the
marks that he made for every confirmed kill.
There's actually a lot less here than he had
in Black Panther and this is obviously because
it takes place earlier in the timeline than
the MCU one.
Using the vibranium spear he impales Tony
and does a nice pun about how he didn't want
him to make the cut.
You might also notice that Tony has a bracelet
on and this is similar to the one that he
had in The Avengers to line up his suit to
his body. I'm guessing that this was used
to summon the drone and it's great that Marvel
managed to show he was already thinking of
automation this early on.
Killmonger drops the great line the difference
between you and me is that you can't see the
difference between you and me.
Killmonger of course said "Just bury me in
the ocean with my ancestors thatjumped from
the ships because they knew death was better
than bondage."
It's up there for me next to lines like "what
is grief if not love perservering" and of
course "do you know what happens to a toad
when it's struck by lightning"
It's at this moment that the Watcher stares
over everything and we see that Killmonger
pins it on the Wakandans which leads to the
US government going to war with them. Every
asset that Stark has is seized and the drones
are mass produced which builds Killmonger
an army that can take down the Wakandan Kingdom.
With Klaue he travels into the jungle which
is where the holographic entrance is revealed.
Klaue calls Killmonger boy and this is often
deemed as a racist term as throughout history
White people used the phrase when talking
to black people to show that they weren't
on equal footing.
Much in the same way that Killmonger took
Klaues corpse into Wakanda to infiltrate their
security he carries him through after murdering
him at point blank range like how he did in
Black Panther.
He reveals the tattoo under his lip and this
was something that he did in Black Pantehr
whilst revealing he was Wakandan to Klaue.
He's taken before the king and we can catch
Okoye to the right hand side. Okoye is the
only Dora Milaje member to wear Gold and this
is because she is the bodyguard for the King.
It's at this point that T'chaka reveals that
he kept Killmonger hidden and this action
of course came back to bite the Wakandans
in Black Panther much like how it does here.
Similar to Tony he's now operating as somewhat
of a Trojan horse and hiding his true intentions.
He lied about his father being murdered by
a gang and T'chaka clearly only accepts him
because he believes he doesn't know the truth.
Shuri is the only one who suspects anything
and it shows off her true intellect.
The Americans roll in and under Killmongers
command we watch as they wait on the outskirts
of Wakanda in a scene that feels very similar
to the battle there that happened at the end
of Infinity War.
Cut to the Drone centre in Nevada where Ross
leads the charge and the shields are opened
much like how they were in IW.
Their power is seemingly destroyed but this
is actually a ruse by Killmonger who activates
the drones, this time under his control. It
leads to an epic final act in which Killmonger
rides into battle against the Drones on the
back of a Rhino. These were of course used
in the finale of Black Panther and Erik pretty
much can't lose because the Drones are of
course inder his command.
It's very much a false flag attack that paints
him out as the hero and he saves Okoye's life
which wins the trust of the Wakandans. The
drones are destroyed and Killmonger stabs
one through the stark logo summising the destruction
of his legacy.
We cut to the Wakandan sunset and in Black
Panther Killmonger remarked on how his father
said that they had the most beautiful ones
in the world. Whereas he died whilst looking
over them this is the beginning of a new chapter
in his life.
He convinces T'Chaka that he should reach
out to their brothers and sisters who are
in dire need across the world and T'Chaka
agrees with him. This was of course his plan
in Black Panther but going about it this way
has worked out way better for him.
He becomes the black panther and is given
the herb that allows one to have the power.
On the ancestral plane he sees the spirit
of T'Challa who appears in his white garb
much like how he did in the film. The pair
debate back and forther and it really shows
the difference between the characters as we
watch Killmonger suit up in the gold uniform
that he had in the movie.
We see Tony's image is used in memorial and
simialr things of course happened in Far From
Home in which he becames an inspiring figure
due to his sacrifice. The poster says only
you can Avenge Tony Stark and ey, no prize
for guessing the wordplay there.
Pepper sees the folly in attacking Wakanda
and she finds Shuri in her office who of course
suspected that her cousin wasn't all that
he seemed to be.
Now we know from the teasers for What If that
Shuri and Pepper will be working together
so expect to see a continuation of this story
at some point in the season.
Now if you've been checking out the trailers
for What If them you'll know theres a big
Avengers assemble moment with several of the
characters from across the series. Amongst
these you can catch Party Thor, T'Challord,
Thanora and lastly Killmonger in his own Black
Panther uniform.
I think that the series is clearly heading
towards a big big team up moment that will
pull a character from each episode and have
them come together in order to face off against
one giant threat. We already know from the
first look that the Strange Supreme version
of the Doc will be meeting with Captain Carter
at some point and it just makes a lot of sense
to have everyone team up to defeat a giant
multiversal enemy that could be destroying
everything.
Now there was a big episode list leak when
the season first started off that said which
episodes had which concept and what order
they would be coming in. Last weeks was actually
listed as being Party Thors and because this
was wrong I thought that the list might be
made up, however it did state that Episode
6 would be the Killmonger one so bar that
episode it's got everything right.
The list stated that the final episode would
be Ultron Infinite and judging by the Hundai
commercial we have a legion of Ultron bots
that the heroes are teaming up to destroy.
Now again the list so far has got everything
right except for the Party Thor one so there
is still potential that it could be wrong
but judging by everything that's going on
around the series it does look pretty accurate.
There are rumours that Disney weren't getting
the expected viewership for the series so
after the Doctor Strange one they moved up
the Zombies episode to help create some hype.
I still think that it's all heading towards
a big team up because well...we've seen the
trailers but whether the Ultron thing is true
or not remains to be seen. However I'd love
to see this Kilmonger amongst the ranks as
he's such a great character.
Marvel are of course known for building their
teams up bit by bit and not only does it look
like they're doing that with the dark avengers
but also the what if heroes which I think
will work really well.
Now as for my thoughts on the episode as a
whole I think this probably ranks amongst
the middle of the list for me. Zombies was
probably my favourite with the Doctor Strange
Episode in a very close second.
However this one was great and I think it's
probably better than all the other ones below
it. I can't believe it's been six weeks now
and the series has flown by but I've really
enjoyed it. I dunno if I'm gonna include everything
in my bi monthly MCU binge that I do but I
think there are some episodes, this one included
that i'll go back to every time as it worked
really well.
If Tony's destiny was changed early on then
it has massive ramifications on the MCU and
outside of the Zombies episode this is the
one that I really hope gets somewhat of a
continuation in the second season.
Now before we close up the video quick spoiler
alert for some new leaks on Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness. If you wanna
dive out the vid then please hit the thumbs
up on the way out and don't let the door hit
you on the way back next week.
You succccka.
Anyway there's been a big plot leak for Doctor
Strange In the Multiverse Of Madness dropped
that says America Chavez will be in the film
and that she will have the ability to open
portals across the multiverse.
She will apparently come from a dimension
in which she is chased by an evil doctor strange
who is none other than What If's Strange Supreme.
Now we did talk about an interview with Benedict
Cumberbatch last week in which he had to hide
his face because he had some spoilers for
the film on and now knowing what we know I
think it makes a lot of sense that this would
be Strange Supreme.
Anyway that's just a minor little update on
what's happening with the ongoing story and
I'd of course love to hear your thoughts on
the brand new What if episode.
Make sure you drop em below and we're running
a competition right now and giving away 3
copies of the Zack Snyder DC Trilogy on the
30th Of September. All you have to do to be
in with a chance of winning is like the video,
make sure you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode. We pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so message
me @heavySpoilers if that's you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of perfect
scene in Spider-Man Homecoming. We break down
the entire thing so it's definitely worth
checking out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time. Take care, Peace